zeig mal was los hier wir
sind
ja deutschland
es tut mir so leid aber es hat sich gelohnt vor ein paar
stunden hi wie geht es dir mein name ist
christophe sollen wir und
yusuf josef posieren okay posieren möglich und hier sind wir
hallo deutschland danke für
danke danke wie fühlst du dich in dem
moment, als ich versuchte zu sagen, dass ich
einfach sehr glücklich bin, hier zu sein, weil ihr
in deutschland uns viel liebe gegeben habt,
also sind wir sehr dankbar dafür und ja
das wetter ist heute scheiße aber drinnen bin ich
immer noch am blasen okay warum ist glow ein hit
besonders in deutschland naja ich denke es liegt
daran ja weil ich denke der
eurovision song contest ist sehr groß in
deutschland und du weißt wann wir gemacht haben was wir gemacht haben
tat an diesem Tag und Auswirkungen hatte es auf
Deutschland und Umgebung war einfach es war
schön so vielen danke ok hast du
dir diesen Erfolg vorgestellt oder was ist dieser Krieg
während einer Überraschung?
zu explodieren, wie es hier unten hat, aber wir
hatten gehofft, weil  Wir haben verstanden, dass
ich ein guter Song war und der Song, kombiniert
mit der Initiative, die wir mit dem
Grand Prix gemacht haben, war auch sehr einzigartig, weißt du,
mit dem Flashmob, also habe ich nur
sehr positiv nachgedacht, was
denkst du, als du das erste Mal gesehen hast
der Flashmob oh mein Gott, ich habe geweint, ich
war nur so traurig, nein traurig, ich war nur, ich war
einfach so froh, aber auch emotional, weil
ich das Gefühl hatte, dass es eine so starke
Kraftaussage war, einen Moment mit
buchstäblich dem ganzen Kontinent zu teilen
48 Minuten lang war ich wirklich
emotional und Sie wissen, was der
Sinn dieses Liedes ist, diese ähm
oder ein Ei zu machen, die Botschaft ist, wir wollen, dass die
ganze Welt zusammen leuchtet, und genau
wie Sie sagten, war Europa für diese acht Minuten
eins für alle  Deutschland Norwegen
Schweden Finnland Wer auch immer Türkei Jeder
war nur eins, also war es eine wunderbare Sache
und das Lied selbst ist ein Repräsentant
für genau das mmhmm ja und du
lebst in Norwegen ist das die Situation
in Norwegen für all die verschiedenen Pes  Ihr Lieben,
ihr wisst, dass wir in Norwegen nicht so viele
Türken haben wie ihr in Deutschland,
aber ihr wisst im Allgemeinen gut, dass ich
sagen möchte, dass wenn wir von Türken
sprechen, ihr wisst, dass
sie in Deutschland mehr Türken sind als Norweger
Anfangs ist das ziemlich verrückt, aber ja, ich
würde in Norwegen sagen, dass Vorurteile
in jedem Land der Welt immer ein Faktor sein werden, aber ich
denke, wir gingen auf eine
bessere Perspektive zu, weil ich in Norwegen
Integration und damit denke
Verschiedene Minderheiten
waren ohne Grund ein neuer Aspekt, also weißt du, dass
es nicht unbedingt die
Politik der Dinge ist, aber es ist nur mehr deine Sache
, weißt du, und dann
flippen die Leute darüber aus, aber jetzt, seit 10 Jahren,
wenn Norweger kommen  unten und ich habe
gesehen, dass das nicht kommen wird, um deine Regierung zu übernehmen,
und wir sind eigentlich
ziemlich okay und ja, also ist es cool, nervig zu sein.
Hast du nach der
Aufführung einige Reaktionen von Leuten gehört
, die sagen: Hey, gut, thi  ng oh gute Nachricht,
ja, absolut, die Resonanz
war gerade überwältigend positiv,
nicht nur in Norwegen, sondern auf dem Kontinent
Europa als Ganzes, denn das ist es, was es
repräsentiert, es fördert nur Positivität
und die Tatsache, dass Sie wissen, ungeachtet
der Tatsache, dass wir verschiedene
Sprachen sprechen  Ich schwöre für besonders Leute
, die in so viele verschiedene Länder reisen, dass
du denkst, du
bist anders als du bist, aber das bist du
nicht
wir stecken den größten teil der arbeit im schlamm
wir sind alle ausländer ja
absolut gleicher scheiss andere toilette ok
das ist ein guter mieter so was ja ich weiter
nächste schritte na ja nächster schritt na ja
ihr wisst wir sind wieder in deutschland wir kommen
hier reisen wir jede Woche durch ganz
Europa, jetzt haben wir das neue Album
, das im Spätsommer oder Herbst herauskommt, also ja,
wir kommen wieder
perfekt, schön, glücklich, glücklich,
glücklich, du darfst sitzen, du darfst sitzen, ok, ok, und
jeder, der Schwarze ist für den
Schwarzen, oh, ok, das ist für
dich  Sie
viele Leute kennen Ihre Songs wie Betteln
, wussten aber nicht, als ich sie fragte: Hey
, das war Mac Metcon, also
haben Sie etwas zu tun, um
in Europa bekannter zu werden. Ja, das ist
auch ein Teil des Jobs  deshalb sind wir
wieder hier, deshalb reisen wir überall
herum, damit Sie wissen, welche Auswirkungen das
Betteln beim ersten Mal
hatte, es war so groß, dass Sie
wissen, dass wir folgen mussten, wir mussten rennen,
und jetzt hier  Punkt mit Glühen, das ist
unsere zweite Single, es ist ein zertifizierter Hit,
also wird es mit dieser hier sein, es wird
besser, besser, es ist ein Problem in
Europa, berühmt zu werden, weil es so
viele Länder gibt, die die Berühmten hören, würde ich
gerne sagen  dass es überhaupt kein Problem ist.
Ich bin sehr Single, also war es früher ein
Problem  em, dass ich keine Freundin habe, aber
heute ist es nicht, weil er deutsche Frauen.
Ich liebe dich wirklich, vielen Dank für
die Liebe und ich habe etwas
am Ende dieses Interviews gehört, dass du gesagt hast,
dass du daran interessiert bist,
mit Bushido zusammenzuarbeiten  einer unserer
berühmtesten Rapper in Deutschland gut,
aber ihr seid Rapper, aber Lo ist nicht der
Repräsentant, nein, das ist gerade auf und ab,
du weißt, es gibt keine Möglichkeit zu versuchen, zu hüpfen,
aber ähm, ja, wir haben Pussy getroffen, obwohl ich mich nicht
erinnern kann, wo  aber es ist eine Weile her
und ich weiß nicht in der Kuppel und ich
weiß es einfach nicht, ja, ich respektiere den
Stil und er schien ein okayer Typ zu sein, und
ja, nichts weiter als das, weißt du,
ja, aber du warst dein Text  Ich möchte
die Menschen vereinen oder näher zusammenbringen.
Bushido hat ein anderes Ziel. Ich denke, er ist
mehr CS-Memoria. Ja, nein, nein, er
will knallen, nur töten
Arbeite mit ihm zusammen, yeah, yeah,
unser gemeinsamer Gro  unds für alle, also machen wir
das mit Bushido, es
wäre cool gewesen, okay, ja, ich bin sehr
interessant, du hast mich zu interessant,
also, was würdest du darüber rappen, weil du
ein Gangster in nein, nein, nicht schon wieder, so sorry,
Bushido sagt dir  Weißt du ich töte Ich sagte nein
nein töte nicht und du weißt wir werden darüber reden wir unterhalten
uns und es ist ok
ok ok ok das ist eine gute Idee ja schau
vielen Dank dir gut